you
[Music]
so my name is Tonya I've been with our
studio for about two years now
so I work in customer success so I work
with several of our enterprise customers
my background is as a therapist so that
was my first career and so I started to
see these principles of resiliency and
some of my strongest are champions and
so I wanted to take some time to talk
through what in our champion is how you
can improve your art championing is that
a word I think it is yeah our
championing and some of the barriers and
some of the ways that I've seen folks be
successful in overcoming those barriers
so who is in our champion well probably
a lot of you here are our champions but
these are some ideas that I came up with
as I was thinking about what an AR
champion is so an our champion is
someone who uses our to accomplish the
core goals and objectives of their job
promotes the use of our within their
group and broader ecosystem that they
live in they contribute to the our
communities through our studio community
and Stack Overflow and other mediums
advocates for and takes ownership of our
tooling in their environment so one of
the things that I'll talk a little bit
more about later on is that sometimes
what I see is that are is installed and
left to IT to manage and the teams that
I see be the most successful are when a
data scientist is really driving there
our tool chain forward and then in our
champion is also someone who stays up to
date on all things AR and freely
disseminates this information so within
their group at work but also through
other mediums so through community
through through our meetups and other
channels so I wanted to add in this
slide four simple ideas to improve your
our champion cred so one easy one is to
organize a Lunch and Learn for just our
analysts or maybe analysts interested in
are in your group and then once you get
this off the ground with your friends
invite more friends from parallel
so how do you get a hold of that start
an internal slack channel so for folks
in your broader organization that are
using ours
so I saw this to be really successful
and one of my accounts were there were
severed several different branches that
were all technically different orgs but
under one broader org and they started a
slack channel for just the for all the
different branches even though there are
technically different companies under
the same parent company and it was
really successful because when someone
ran into a problem with their our code
they could rely on their colleague their
broader colleagues in their bigger
ecosystem for help the intentional about
connecting with other our users at our
meetups and our conferences and talk
about the barriers that you're running
into because chances are you're not
alone it can when you run into a barrier
or someone says no to something that you
want to do chances are you're it can
feel very isolated but chances are
you're not alone someone else has run
into that so talk about you know the
50,000 foot view of how things are going
in your organization's with other our
users so what are some of the barriers
now that I got y'all stoked about being
at our champion what are some of the
barriers that you might run into so
these are definitely not all of the
barriers but this is a short talk so I
can't go through all of them so these
are just a few of the ones that I came
up with so some of the ones that I see
are the open source mentality so that
was kind of twofold why should we trust
open source tools and why should we pay
for open source tools funding issues
there's not enough money IT support and
then of course internal political
pressure everyone's favorite so why why
trust
open source are so one of the things
that I've I've learned a lot about in my
role as it is the different the
different mentality so the old-school
thought before open source became you
know being you became utilized in
enterprise settings was that you buy
your software from a big company that
wrote the software and then you have to
pay for support to support that stuff
we're and I don't know if you've ever
bought a software from a big company and
then had it not function as you
anticipated and it's hard to really
validate that because it's it's close
source right you cannot see the source
code you can't validate for yourself
that the software or the software will
perform as anticipated so active
software utilization is more the open
source mentality the code is all there
and you have to you can go in look at
the software look at the code and make
sure it'll do what you need it to do and
I will say it's a little bit higher
investment with the ActiveX software
utilization so that's sometimes where
you get some resistance is the fact that
it does you're you're taking ownership
of it and you're validating it yourself
so the nice thing about that though is
open-source technology it's really hard
to hide faulty software there's kind of
nowhere to hide your source code is out
there if it doesn't work you're gonna
find out really quickly and the
community is not going to be happy so
that's another big benefit is that is
that you can validate your own your own
software it is a higher investment
though so there's a strong community for
our developers and our platform
administrators so we're doing more and
more on our studio community to support
the IT folks who are who are supporting
the platform for analysts and last but
not least sometimes you can run into
issues with your legal team or your info
security team and there is commercially
licensed are and tools for are available
and sometimes that can help us wage some
of the legal concerns when you're
switching between or when you're moving
more towards an open source software so
ok now that you've got the open source
software why should we pay for tooling
around that open source software there's
a few different reasons so performance
so I don't know if you've had any
experience with the open source tools
versus the professional tools but
typically you have a little bit better
performance definitely with the server
products that we have
you have improved performance it can be
deployed in a more secure fashion you
can have things like authentication kind
of locking it down and that helps
InfoSec feel feel more more confident in
the tools and then you can have
increased collaboration with your
colleagues and then with connect and
other tools you can do some automations
you can automate out some reporting you
can do you can also have a commercial
license which kind of talked about
before but you can the you can have some
legal coverage which makes legal happier
you also get maintenance and support and
someone like me and support and
solutions engineering to give you ideas
about how you might want to set up the
software and give you suggestions so
that can be really valuable as well and
then there's this idea that tarrif
talked about in his keynote yesterday of
Technology philanthropy so by investing
as an enterprise in enterprise toolchain
for our we're also helping the broader
our community in them and our studio
community as well so this is another one
that I hear a lot funning there's not
enough room in the budget how many
people have run into funding barriers
yeah yeah it's really common this is
probably the top one that I hear so my
best advice for coming overcoming the
funding issues is just to create use the
open source tool chain so really deep
dive on creating api's creating really
valuable shiny apps so show them what's
possible and then be able to communicate
what else is possible with the with the
tool chain so I like folks to start with
the open source tool train and create a
demand for a parameterised or markdown
so really deep dive into the open source
tool chain and a lot is actually
possible with the open source tools so
collaborate with parallel teams through
your our community so once you've built
up in our community collaborate with
those teams I've seen several teams be
successful in collaborating and resource
sharing so two different teams and
different organizations
one software that's definitely possible
or if there is a team in your
organization that's been successful with
funding they may know how they may have
ideas for you as to how they got that
funding made available to them and then
I kind of covered this in my first point
clearly communicate the possibilities
with open source and the possibilities
with professional software so once you
have your proof of concept there are
valuations of all of our professional
products that can allow you the
opportunity to demonstrate what's
possible what else is possible and once
you create that appetite I've seen funds
become available oh the last one asked
good questions so I think sometimes when
when we're told no the automatic
responses and and and it can be hard to
kind of pull yourself together and
approach that with curiosity oh okay is
is there any funding changes in the
future that you can see coming down the
road what about our tool chain for next
year is there gonna be any additional
funding so sometimes just getting over
the oh and going to approaching it with
curiosity can be successful in kind of
problem-solving and the way I like to
think of it is help your manager or
whoever whoever told you know solve your
problem so you want to get them bought
in ask a lot of how what open-ended
questions in a very curious manner
because you're really trying to do them
a service at this point when you're
asking for tooling no one just asks for
tools just to have a bigger toolbox the
other thing that I hear occasionally is
from IT we can't set up something that
is free there needs to be a commitment
from the business again asking good
questions becomes really really
important here so what commitment is
necessary to use open-source tools what
does commitment look like can you give
me an idea of
that looks like is there a separate team
that manages open source software so
I've had several several of my larger
accounts that I will work with there's
the IT team that they always use and
that chain says no and then they don't
really know where else to go
but sometimes within your organization
there's a research group that's kind of
like a mad science lab where they're
deploying different software and
sometimes those mad scientist groups are
way more willing to take a chance on
open-source and another thing to think
about is you know they're saying no to
our but I can almost promise you there's
Python somewhere what team is managing
Python like is there a team for a manet
for for managing open source software so
sometimes it requires a little
out-of-the-box thinking to find the
right team all right let's see it did I
get all the points yes
oh yeah and asking about the specific
policies because sometimes they'll say
no that's that's not in line with our
policy well okay great what is so
sometimes just you know going back and
asking a good what question can can be
really helpful there's also a few
different options from a technical
perspective so we do have pre-configured
virtual machines on all of the major
cloud platform so AWS Google Cloud I
think a sure as of recently Kelly says
yes okay good thank you Kelly
and then yeah find those find those
open-source policy documents yeah I hit
that one twice really important and then
the last thing is explore external
partners so if you're really kind of
spinning your wheels you can't find
anyone in your IT group or your mad
scientist Ike to group that wants to set
this up then we do we can help you find
a partner that can come in and set up
the server and sometimes I have several
folks that will need to do that just get
anything done I'm getting close to time
so I'm going to hurry yep so political
pressure for other tools and languages
so not every tool is right for every
problem don't argue for one tool instead
argue for more
fools again I like this idea of
curiosity and I've seen it be really
successful so asking about the features
that they saw in the product like what
what is their tangible takeaway that
they're interested in are they
interested in a dashboard are they
interested in a report what is the
takeaway and then in the back of your
head be thinking about could I show them
something similar with the open source R
so just asking those good questions so
that you understand what their needs are
and then you have the your are skills
that you can think about how to create
that with with the tool chain that you
prefer so how does this align with with
our goals and needs so asking about how
the software what direction are we going
as a team and this can be really good
for helping helping you navigate through
your career what other tools are
available for me so if I run into
problems what are my other options so
again you're kind of recruiting them to
help them solve your problem and so just
through curiosity I mean letting them
letting them telling them kind of what's
possible and then more tools is not
necessarily bad you can definitely have
too many tools but a toolbox with just a
bunch of hammers is not that helpful and
this photo it would be helpful to have a
screwdriver last but not least you can
do it I've seen a lot of people run into
some really stubborn barriers and I've
seen these concepts work in action so
you can do it you can advocate for your
tool chain and you can be successful
using the tools that you prefer to use
all right questions
[Applause]
do you see our studio konnekt as a good
way to initially get in the door I guess
with art an organization yeah definitely
so mmm
I think our studio konnekt is a great
way because of the emailing feature so
every executive that's consuming your
reports is attached to their inbox and
so if you can show them the automated
reporting where they can get their daily
reports sent to them at the same time
every day and that can include metadata
in the subject title that's a golden way
to get buy-in in our studio konnekt you
can even do some really nice HTML email
formatting so that it looks really great
in their inbox and I think if more
executives were able to see that they
would get more excited about the our
studio professional tool chain
specifically connect experience working
it with public sector agencies where I
mean I'm from Washington State and the
Department of Health and Microsoft is
kind of a religion there you know and so
we have all you know contracts with all
these things and I you know trying to
slip this stuff in is more than
challenging yeah definitely so um we
have several folks so actually that the
team that I worked with that had this
giant slack channel they were actually
in the public sector so there's and the
other thing from a legal contracts per
set perspective you probably know
purchasing anything with the government
I mean like you need like so much
there's so much red tape but we're doing
more in terms of contracts partnering
with folks that actually RGS on the GSA
schedule and other things that public
sector and government organizations
really need it is possible there are
more barriers and it generally takes
longer but we're doing more and more to
make it easier to purchase from us
you
[Music]